[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver à
la Une de Ça vous regarde ce soir
peut-on se passer de l'agriculture
intensive des poules en cage des ports
derrière les barreaux la cruauté envers
les animaux et dénoncer de toutes parts
une proposition de loi débattue demain à
l'Assemblée propose de sortir de
l'élevage en batterie d'ici 20 ans
est-ce un délai raisonnable pourquoi la
majorité s'y oppose des réponses tout de
suite dans notre grand débat on parlera
aussi de cette guerre aux portes de
l'Europe les forces arméniennes et
azerbaïdjanaise s'affrontent depuis une
semaine dans le haut carabar des deux
côtés les civils sont prises au piège
des bombardements la Turquie s'invite
dans le conflit la France doit-elle
choisir son camp décryptage à suivre
enfin notre grand aimant témoin ce soir
est l'un des députés les plus baroques à
l'Assemblée il a tenté sa chance à Paris
sans succès revient-il au Palais Bourbon
avec un peu d'amertume nous poserons la
question à Cédric Villani notre invité
ce soir voilà donc pour le programme
hashtag pour réagir sur Twitter tout de
suite notre grand débat
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi LCP
juste avant de vous présenter mes
invités un petit mot d'abord sur ce sur
cette petite blouse blanche que Stéphane
blackovski et moi-même à Bordeaux
arboron ce soir la chaîne et partenaire
du pasteur don et s'il y a bien un
moment il faut soutenir nos chercheurs
nos scientifiques et la recherche en
général celle de l'Institut Pasteur
c'est bien maintenant à l'ombre
soutenons la recherche au 36 20 ou sur
pasteurdon.fr on en reparlera à la fin
de l'émission
en vous entendant de rappeler de noter
que aujourd'hui le prix Nobel est venu
récompenser deux chercheuses dont une
Française pour la découverte de chrisper
cast nine et les et les fameuses
recherches sur l'édition de génome vous
avez choisi le meilleur moment pour
arborer cette blouse cocorico petit
cocorico mais justement je voulais vous
faire réagir attendez parce que
justement vous allez un peu vite en
besoin bonsoir d'abord Cédric bonsoir
merci d'être on ne vous présente plus
député de l'Essonne on le dit quand même
député EDS ça c'est cassé démocratie
solidarité vous avez rejoint ce groupe
parlementaire après avoir été exclu de
la République en marche à cause de votre
candidature dissidente à Paris vous
allez vous dire comment vous vous sentez
dans ce groupe est-ce que vous regrettez
celui de la majorité quels sont vos
projets pour l'éthique pour la suite
mais d'abord l'actualité elle vous
concerne puisque demain vous allez
soutenir une proposition de loi sur le
bien-être animal et on a décidé de
débattre de cette question précise qui
concerne votre texte ce soir peut-on
nourrir la France sans l'élevage
intensif bonsoir Jean-Baptiste Moreau
ravi de vous retrouver sur ce plateau
vous êtes député la République en marche
éleveur de vaches dans la Creuse et
bonsoir Nicolas Giraud bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes porte-parole de la
Confédération paysanne également éleveur
dans le Jura Étienne gangneron le
vice-président de la FNSEA va nous
rejoindre dans un instant et puis
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam Stéphane
blackovski qui comme tous les soirs
m'accompagne Agne et ouvre le bal de ce
grand débat si j'ai bien compris tout de
suite
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir Stéphane si
j'ai bien compris Myriam il y a une
chose qui est sûr c'est que les Français
ne supportent plus pour l'immense pour
leur immense majorité de savoir qu'on
fait souffrir les animaux qu'on fait les
sondages sur la question les résultats
sont toujours très très éloquents là je
vous ai pris un sondage de l'époque on
voit que plus de 90 % des Français
pensent que le bien-être animal c'est
important et les plus motivés ce sont
les jeunes qui pensent non pas que c'est
important de pas faire souffrir les
animaux mais que c'est même très
important de ne pas les faire souffrir
donc c'est un phénomène récent se soucis
du bien-être animal ou pas et ben pas
tant que ça pas tant que ça puisque qui
vérification sur Wikipédia nous permet
de voir que la SPA la Société
protectrice des animaux a été fondée en
1845 donc ça ne date vraiment pas d'hier
mais quand on s'intéresse à vos motifs
de la création c'est-à-dire qu'à
l'époque
ce qui a poussé à la création de la SPA
c'est peut-être que les chevaux étaient
très maltraités dans les rues de Paris
ce qui fait que les citadins ça les
heurtaient de voir des chevaux parfois
mal nourris mal soignés surtout qui
était développé par leur cocher donc
c'est ça l'explication de la Fondation
ça veut dire quoi en fait ça veut dire
que ce qui rend la souffrance animale
intolérable c'est le moment où elle
s'offre en spectacle aux yeux de tous
donc ce qui fait que pendant des années
finalement pour traiter cette question
de la souffrance animale qu'est-ce qu'on
a fait et ben on a caché la souffrance
animale et du coup bah forcément plus
personne n'en souffrait et on avait
l'air on a l'impression que ça
n'existait pas mais finalement
aujourd'hui bien sûr ce n'est plus
possible parce que vous faites référence
évidemment c'est vidéo je vous donne la
parole je laisse terminer Stéphane
d'abord à ses vidéos souvent tournées en
caméra cachée vidéo choc dans les
abattoirs ou dans les dans les élevages
intensifs exactement bah alors tant que
les élevages restaient clos et que leur
porte était fermée bah finalement ce
souci la souffrance animale ça nous
préoccupait pas tant que ça et puis
maintenant qu'on voit les vidéos
forcément les premières vidéos ont
vraiment fait un choc et même
aujourd'hui quand on revoit par exemple
des images de des images par mois de
poules en cage c'est toujours des images
choquantes
[Musique]
voilà est-ce que cette prise de
conscience elle a fait avancer les
choses ça fait inventer les choses mais
c'est doucement et ce qui est sûr que ce
qui bouge ça bougeait c'est que c'est
devenu un enjeu politique aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire qu'on les politiques sont
obligés d'en tenir compte Emmanuel
Macron quand il était candidat en 2017
parmi ses promesses vous voyez il avait
tweeté à l'époque il avait engagé il
était engagé donc comme il l'avait dit
sur ce tweet à ce que les autres poules
ne soient plus disponibles soient plus
vendus dans les grandes surfaces à
partir de 2022 ou 3 m pour le une
promesse pour le bien-être cette
promesse de campagne promesse tenue ou
pas en fait oui elle est tenue dans le
sens où il était inscrite dans la loi
mais elle est pas tenue dans le sens où
on en serait déjà arrivé
on soit sûr d'arriver en 2022 à ce qu'il
n'y ait plus de ses œufs enfin fournis
par des poules élevés en cage on voit
les statistiques aujourd'hui sur les
quels sont les animaux qui sont
produits de manière intensive vous voyez
que les poules il y a eu un vrai progrès
notamment pour les poules pondeuses ça
baisse je crois que c'est encore plus
bas aujourd'hui en revanche c'est plus
c'est pas du tout le cas pour les lapins
ou les ports qui sont majoritairement
élevés dans des élevages intensifs donc
le paradoxe cette question je vous ai
dit les Français à 80% disent ben nous
on est contre l'élevage intensif mais en
même temps quand on voit que 95% des
cochons sont élevés en élevage intensif
et que les Français continuent d'en
manger il y a quelque chose qui colle
pas entre d'un côté l'amour des animaux
qu'on proclame et le comportement donc
oui on a une vraie pression contre
l'élevage intensif mais savoir quand
est-ce que ça sera interdit ça c'est
vraiment une autre histoire c'est une
question le délai vous parlez de 20 ans
Cédric Villani avant de vous d'arriver
dans le détail pour rebondir sur sur le
billet de Stéphane vous êtes tous
d'accord pour dire autour de cette table
que l'élevage industriel l'élevage
intensif et synonyme de souffrance
animale
Cédric Villani
évidemment il faut d'abord s'entendre ce
que ça veut dire élevage intensif et
quand je dis élevage intensif pour moi
ce sont trois choses à la fois ou trois
choses qu'on retrouve une forte densité
de population le fait d'être enfermé
souvent pas avoir la lumière du jour et
la sélection de race d'animaux qui sont
sélectionnés pour leur production par
exemple typique et qui franchit choquant
aussi pas seulement pour les cages
exemple typique pour les poulets sont
ces poulets qu'on voit dans certains
élevages qui ont des pattes à peine qui
peuvent à peine soutenir le poids de
leur corps parce que dans l'industrie on
a besoin davantage de blances filées que
de que de pâtes si je puis dire et donc
ces trois caractéristiques disons
définiront élevage intensif et pour moi
ce n'est pas le bon modèle d'élevage
pour l'avenir
sur le diagnostic est-ce qu'il y a bien
un problème
un élevage intensif ou un élevage
industriel parce que déjà il faut
définir le mot parce que si on veut
légiférer correctement il faut définir
le mot un animal
l'enfermement enfin je veux dire les
vaches sont enfermées dans des enclos
aussi si on va par là enfin je veux dire
très exigu mais très exigus les normes
n'ont cessé de progresser sur le
bien-être animal depuis 20 ans grosso
modo le nombre de poules par cash
notamment et de la de lapin aussi mais
la place des mutilations c'est pas un
animal heureux on peut avoir des
bâtiments des choses
c'est pas un animal en extérieur meurt
enfin
il y a des pourcentages de mortalité il
y a des essais qui ont été pratiqués sur
le lapin sur l'élevage de lapin en plein
air en Autriche en Allemagne les taux de
mentalité en exposés ont explosé je suis
pas sûr qu'un animal mort sur un animal
heureux ou pouvoir situation de
bien-être donc c'est pour ça que il faut
pas faire de l'anthropomorphisme il y a
des comportements animaux qui ne sont
pas les comportements humains un animal
n'est dans un être humain c'est
différent c'est pas moins bien c'est pas
mieux mais c'est différent
d'élevage comme étant des êtres
sensibles et c'est là où je suis pas
d'accord avec l'édito de Blacko pour une
fois je suis souvent d'accord avec lui
mais sur le bien-être animal les animaux
étaient pas plus maltraités avant
l'éleveur il a à cœur le bien-être de
ses animaux parce que de toute façon
déjà il vit tous les jours avec et
toutes les nuits et donc il a aucun
intérêt à les maltraiter même
économiquement il a aucun intérêt un
animal qui est maltraité ne produit pas
donc c'est ça n'a aucun sens c'est
intéressant
parce qu'il est égal entre page intensif
et souffrance animale est-ce que vous
vous le faites Jean-Baptiste nuance on
sait par exemple que les poules
elles se font mal elles se parfois voilà
elle se blesse on est obligé de limer
leur bec pour ne pas qu'il y ait des
mutilations à l'intérieur de ces cages
Nicolas Giraud là où je suis d'accord
c'est que il faut encore une fois se
mettre d'accord sur les termes élevage
intensifs élevage industriel nous on
n'est pas exactement la même chose
derrière quand on parle
d'industrialisation de l'agriculture on
parle de ce qu'on fait subir à l'animal
de ce qu'on fait subir aussi au monde
paysan il faut aussi qu'on replace ça
dans un contexte économique où est-ce
que comment est-ce qu'on a fait pour en
arriver là pourquoi est-ce que
aujourd'hui encore quasiment 50% des
poules pondeuses sont en cage c'est
aussi parce que il y a une une vision
économique une volonté de produire plus
à moins cher dans une économie
globalisée dans une libéralisation des
marchés qui a poussé les paysans en
arrivait là aujourd'hui
pour nous euh le l'enjeu de remettre au
cœur des des discussions politiques la
bien traitance animale c'est pas
exactement la même chose que le
bien-être animal là bien traitant ça va
être l'acte du de la paysanne ou du
paysan sur ses animaux comment est-ce
qu'il les accompagnent comment est-ce
qu'ils travaillent avec eux au quotidien
l'enjeu de remettre ça au cœur du débat
politique c'est c'est vraiment la
question de de comment est-ce que on
travaille en collaboration avec nos
animaux et et quel élevage on veut et
quelle agriculture on veut on va y venir
mais je voudrais d'abord saluer Étienne
gang Ron bonsoir merci d'être là si vous
n'étiez pas là tout de suite c'est pour
des raisons de nombreux de place à cause
du covid donc n'en soyez pas n'en soyez
pas déçus je rappelle que vous êtes le
vice-président de la FNSEA sur ce
diagnostic
l'élevage intensif qu'on a essayé de
définir en train de forcément de la
souffrance il y a pas de définition
d'élevage intensif où élevage industriel
donc en fait on qualifie l'é industriels
de manière complètement absurde puisque
il y a pas il y a pas de modèle aussi
identiques qu'on voudrait bien croire et
moi je connais des gens que vous
qualifiez peut-être d'agriculteurs en
élevage intensif qui adore leurs animaux
et qui font le maximum comme la Dijon
Baptiste jour et nuit pour que ça se
passe bien donc et après moi je là où je
suis en difficulté par rapport au
diagnostic que vous posez au Nicolas
pose c'est que il y a aussi le problème
du du revenu de l'agriculteur c'est à
dire que on a oui mais entendre
la souffrance animale ce problème
existe-t-il est-ce que par exemple vous
considérez à la FNSEA que les lanceurs
d'alerte type L214 on fait avancer la
cause du bien-être animal non non nous
on considère que L214 a fait un travail
monstrueux de ne montrer que ce qui va
pas de jamais valoriser les bonnes
pratiques de jamais accompagner les
éleveurs à changer de pratique alors ils
ont un discours qui est très ambigu mais
dans la mesure où il ne passe que des
vidéos trash qui souvent sont même pas
tourner en France on sait on connaît pas
toujours l'origine des des images
c'est assez catastrophique il pourrait
faire ça dans n'importe quel milieu dans
n'importe quelle entreprise ne filmer
que des actes limites des gens qui ont
des comportements limites les
additionner en deux minutes de vidéo 50
heures de visionnage et vous prenez deux
minutes vous prenez deux minutes il y a
de la manipulation Cédric
allez-y pardon la difficulté c'est que
pour véritablement accompagner les
éleveurs pour changer le le système ca
priori la société ne veut plus il faut
déjà qualifier le type d'élevage qu'on
peut il faut payer les produits mais il
faut aussi que les citoyens qui votent
très majotent majoritairement pour
l'amélioration des conditions de vie des
animaux seraient interroge sur les 80
000 abandons d'animaux domestiques sur
comment vit un chien ou un chien dans un
appartement H24 en ville toute l'année
est sortie deux minutes le soir pour
aller faire ses besoins dehors il faut
aussi là dessus je pense c'est trop
facile de critiquer ce qu'on ne connaît
pas il faudrait déjà reportage
possible mais mais juste pour répondre à
la FNSE Cédric Villani déjà est-ce qu'on
a progressé est-ce que c'est mieux avant
c'était mieux c'est mieux aujourd'hui
qu'avant c'est pas la bonne question
est-ce que c'est mieux aujourd'hui
qu'avant la question c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire dans le futur et quand on
voit maintenant qu'on a d'après les
chiffres de présenter tout à l'heure 99%
de l'élevage de lapins qui se fait en
cage on se dit on peut pas considérer ça
comme un modèle pérenne j'entends bien
que lapin est fragile mais je peux pas
croire que lapin en cage il soit
simplement heureux je veux bien que les
éleveurs de lapin fassent leur maximum
mais un lapin
c'est un animal qui a besoin de courir
c'est animal qui qui saute c'est un
animal qui mobile agile vous le mettez
en cage je vois pas comment même avec la
meilleure volonté du monde même en le
donnant le plus d'amour possible il va
être heureux là où je rejoins monsieur
Ganneron c'est sur la question
fondamentale du revenu de l'agriculteur
et de l'éleveur on a les statistiques
aussi qui sont un véritable scandale.pi
qui nous disent sur 100 euros dans
l'agroalimentaire et n'as 6 à 7 qui
reviennent ces producteur
c'est un scandale comment une grande
nation d'élevage d'agriculture peut
accepter ça c'est un grand dossier dont
on a beaucoup parlé d'alimentation sur
la grande distribution mais en même
temps rétribuer payer valoriser le
travail seulement la question du revenu
la question de la rentabilité
d'alternative à l'élevage intensif on va
tout de suite la regarder de façon
extrêmement pratique et concrète avec ce
reportage tourné dans le Morvan à la
rencontre d'un exploitant de port qui
vous allez le voir gambade à ciel ouvert
c'est signé Clément Perrot regardez
[Musique]
Fabrice voit l'eau élève une
cinquantaine de ports dans cette
parcelle de maïs le tout dans le parc
régional du Morvan le grand luxe pour
une vie de cochon avec la canicule de
fin septembre ça leur servait d'ombrage
et aujourd'hui ça leur sert de jeu dans
la boue je ne je n'ai pas la psychologie
du cochon mais je pense qu'ils sont
heureux oui évidemment on le voit très
bien ils sont pas sauvages ils sont pas
apeurés
ses ports sont ici pour leur phase
d'engraissement qui dure 5 mois ils sont
d'une race standard la même que dans les
élevages intensifs et d'après l'éleveur
ils sont parfaitement adaptés aux plein
air on a eu les fortes canicules on a eu
la neige on a eu les gelées on a eu le
froid des -10 - 12 sans aucun souci
majeur
je mets Fabrice voit l'eau élève surtout
des vaches charolaises les cochons pour
lui c'est juste une activité de
complément cela lui rapporte autour de
2500 euros par an
avec 8 autres éleveurs il est intégré à
une filière haut de gamme baptisée port
plein air Morvan c'est un fabricant
d'aliments qui l'organisme avec 1000
ports par an la production reste
confidentielle et n'a pas vocation à
s'élargir des mesures aimant c'est un
marché de niche on pourrait pas faire
que du port plein air pour nourrir toute
la France c'est pas possible pourquoi
mais aujourd'hui c'est des cycles qui
sont assez assez long nous on fait du
port de 5 mois 6 mois contre du port
qu'on va faire standard à 3 mois et demi
les animaux ils ont 120 mètres carrés
par cochon en bâtiment on est plutôt à
0,65 m² par cochon donc si on mettait
tous les cochons de bâtiments dehors
mais il nous faudrait vraiment une
surface énorme quoi
[Musique]
aujourd'hui cette viande s'adresse
d'abord à une clientèle d'amateurs
exigeant ou de consommateurs soucieux du
bien-être animal
la problématique dans son ensemble moi
aussi j'ai un ami en Creuse qui élève
des cochons en plein air trois petits
cochons il fait des charcuteries
exceptionnels
dans le reportage si vous voulez libérer
mettre les cochons dehors partout c'est
500 mille hectares qu'il faut sceller la
grandeur d'un département français qu'il
faut mettre consacrer uniquement à
l'élevage de porc alors il va falloir
trouver les surfaces déjà d'une et de 2
ce qu'on prépare là c'est une société de
vitesse c'est pas plus sur ce time là
comme sur d'autres une agriculture à
deux vitesses avec une société à deux
vitesses avec les gens qui ont les
moyens qui achèteront effectivement les
portes plein air et puis les gens qui
n'ont pas les moyens qui achèteront des
animaux d'importation
parce que parce que les on est sur un
marché commun européen et que les
animaux les pores allemands seront moins
chers et donc ils arrivent ensuite
je vous redonne la parole de dire ça
enfin c'est aussi de votre de votre
responsabilité de politique de de voir
comment est-ce qu'on arrive à aller vers
ce modèle là qui est publicité
plébiscité bien sûr que si on sort tous
les ports on y arrivera pas est-ce qu'on
a besoin de produire autant de port que
ce qu'on produit actuellement en France
est-ce qu'on a besoin de consommer
autant de viande que ce qu'on consomme
aujourd'hui en France est-ce qu'on a pas
à revoir notre modèle agricole notre
modèle alimentaire et en fonction de ça
en fonction des besoins est-ce qu'on
n'est pas capable de répondre à la fois
aux enjeux des paysans en maîtrisant en
régulant les productions on sait le
faire quand on maîtrise je sais d'où je
viens je viens d'une filière à compter
qui sait maîtrisée qui s'est rémunéré
qui sait faire de la qualité qui sait
répondre à ces enjeux là si on arrive à
faire ça on peut être capable de
rémunérer on peut être capable de
relocaliser si on protège les paysans et
on peut pas être capable en ayant ce
type de production de répondre aux
enjeux de bien-être animal et
d'alimentation de qualité
c'est des décisions politiques à prendre
en main et vous refusez de les prendre
en compte
et elle peut répondre
il y a des décisions politiques mais il
y a surtout le le modèle de consommation
clairement aujourd'hui quand le le
ménage moyen mais 12% d'alimentation
alors que dans les années 50 c'était 40
%, il y a eu des choix qui ont été faits
c'est-à-dire que les gens préfèrent
acheter un écran plat 5 téléphones et
tout et ne pas consacrer beaucoup
d'argent à leur alimentation
le politique le politique quand on fait
la politique c'est se dire on va prendre
en main les choses pour que ça soit
mieux un peu mieux beaucoup mieux que si
on laissait les choses se faire toute
seule oui mais on change pas ensuite
entre les 150 mètres carrés qui étaient
évoqués tout à l'heure et le 0,7 m² qui
était là pour le pour l'élevage en
caillebotis caillebotis ça dépend du
poids c'est un peu plus qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire conventionnel de port 1m² par
bête à l'autre bout du spectre vous avez
le Label rolabel Rouge fermier pour le
port c'est 250 m² de parcours entre l'un
et l'autre du besoin de plus d'espace
elle est réel mais de l'un à l'autre
vous avez toute une gamme
ne serait-ce que passer d'un mètre carré
à 10 mètres carrés voir 5 m², ça va
changer la condition de vie
ça dépend de combien on met ça dépend de
si on compte est-ce que c'est un accès à
l'extérieur un accès Planet maximale
mais la question même ce que je dirais
ce qui est important on peut pas juste
dire un département qui se consacre à
faire de faire du port ou une grande
surface et la surface est dans les dans
ces modèles dans ces modèles
d'agroécologie tels que nous les
appelons de nos vœux dans mon groupe
écologie démocratie solidarité tel qu'on
peut les voir dans certaines
réalisations il y a pas d'un côté le
port de l'autre côté les vaches et puis
les cultures ça fait des tout intégrés
où il y a des compléments des uns des
autres les animaux d'élevage qui donnent
de l'engrais pour la pour l'agriculture
l'agriculture qui sert en partie à
nourrir les animaux c'est un tout
intégré avec des rotations donc ça
dépend des animaux et ça et vous et je
rappelle que vous voulez une transition
une transition en 20 ans vous avez dans
votre texte
le projet de société absolument
cage si je vous ai bien lu 10 ans pour
en finir avec les pores et les lapins en
batterie et 20 ans pour permettre
l'accès en plein air à tous les animaux
d'élevage est-ce que c'est faisable dans
on a déjà inscrit on a déjà marqué
l'interdiction de reconstruire tout
nouveau poulailler pour des qui mettrai
des poules en cage et la filière
peu importe puisque de toute façon la
filière la filière aujourd'hui c'était
engagé en 2017 à être à 50% de poules
autrement qu'en cage à horizon 2020 elle
y était déjà en 2019
bien sûr que c'est réalisable enfin si
on s'en donne les moyens si on se donne
les moyens on impose pas aux
consommateurs de changer son mode de
consommation
mais en même temps on a la Pâques on a
on a des leviers économiques qui sont
importants au niveau européen donc au
niveau français comment est-ce qu'on
peut dire consommateurs
comment est-ce qu'on peut se servir de
la Pâques pour réinstaller des gens pour
faire les changements de pratique pour
cesser d'avoir une course à
l'agrandissement et à l'intensification
donc à l'industrialisation enfin nous on
a écrit un bouquin cause animale cause
paysanne pour lier les deux enjeux parce
qu'il nous semble que les deux enjeux
sont liés comme je dis au début si on a
plus de paysans on pourra répondre à
l'agroécologie on pourra bien on pourra
répondre au bien-être animal mais le
consommateur le consommateur excusez-moi
je finis je finis le consommateur il a
envie de manger comme il faut
aujourd'hui il a du mal parce que ça
revient de fait plus cher si on arrive à
avoir une PAC qui réoriente ses
subventions vers un élevage de bien
traitant animal qui se relocalise et qui
et qui est à l'écoute de des enjeux des
paysans des consommateurs et de son
environnement il sera compétitif cet
élevage là il sera compétitions
un changement de modèle on est d'accord
sur le fait que la cause animale et la
cause paysanne elle est liée évidemment
le fait de dissocier de parler que
bien-être animal et de pas prendre en
compte l'équilibre qui a entre les
hommes et les animaux dans l'élevage
c'est c'est malheureusement ce qui se
fait avec les sondages qu'on voit les
gens s'orientent uniquement sur le
bien-être animal il y a un édito récent
d'un d'une journaliste bien connu qui
disait et les humains attendront il y a
cette espèce d'angle qui est infernale
nous il faut qu'on emmène tout le monde
ensemble évidemment mais où Nicolas
Giraud se trouve c'est que la
réorientation de la pacte l'orientation
de la PAC par rapport au sujet de ce
soir sur l'élevage intensif ce sont les
filières qui touchent le moins d'impact
la volaille et l'époque sont
pratiquement à 0 aide pack et ben
justement c'est possible de changer
alors
là il y a une question qui revient qui
est centrale c'est la question de la
rentabilité c'est la question du coup la
transition ça coûterait combien
d'ailleurs de sortir
alors j'ai posé la question dans les
auditions il y a eu beaucoup d'auditions
dans les travaux préparateurs cette
proposition doit bien sûr j'ai posé la
question à des représentants des
différents syndicats agricoles sur la
question de sur la question des ports
port si vous voulez pour moi c'est un
cas emblématique aussi parce que c'est
un animal qu'on regarde qu'on assume à
regarder de près récemment d'encore plus
près je dirais avec la science dont on a
découvert que pour l'intelligence il le
sait dans rien même au chien vous me
direz c'est connu plus longtemps sans
doute on savait on dit souvent dans la
ferme le cochon animal intelligent il
faudrait aider les agriculteurs de
combien pour passer et la réponse qu'on
a entendu j'ai entendu j'ai entendu
entre 7 et 13 milliards c'est ça le
chiffre que j'ai entendu quand j'ai
demandé aux organisations combien
d'investissements il faudrait pour
permettre à tous les bâtiments avoir un
accès
j'économique
sur 20 ans sur 20 ans sur 20 ans sur 20
ans ça représente 3 centimes par jour et
par français oui mais
je suis d'accord les chiffres sont
exacts ça c'est la transition le
problème c'est qu'on transitionne on
fait en transit vers quoi vers un modèle
qui n'a pas de rentabilité puisque le
consommateur n'est pas prêt à payer le
prix pour pour ces ports là donc je veux
dire
évidemment boucherie alors j'entends
l'argument il faut consommer moins de
viande déjà c'est c'est un argument de
pays riche parce que et puis de
personnes riches parce que dans en
France tout le monde ne mange pas de la
viande à tous les repas et globalement
au niveau français la moyenne elle est
en dessous des préoccupes des
préconisations de l'OMS en consommation
de viande par habitant le problème est
différent aux États-Unis où il y a des
consommations massives de viande là on
est d'accord mais en France c'est déjà
pas le cas on consomme déjà moins de
viande que les préconisations
climatique
un peu trop par contre
[Musique]
une ferme usine qui est aujourd'hui dans
la Somme où il y a un peu plus de 800
vaches pour faire du lait et non pas
forcément souffrance animale mais mais
en tout cas des animaux meilleurs
présents dans un bâtiment pour produire
plus pour produire à moins cher pour
rémunérer moins les paysans et pour
entasser les animaux et ça pour nous ça
n'a plus aucun sens ça n'a plus aucun
sens pour nous ça ne plus aucun sens
pour les consommateurs et pourtant ce
modèle là accapare déprime parce que il
accapare des hectares et les aides de la
PACS sont donnés sur les hectares plus
on est gros plus on touche de prime donc
un moment donné si on est capable de se
dire on veut changer de modèle on est
capable de dire on change les
orientations politiques européennes
c'est difficile mais
est-ce que la France est-ce que la
France ne peut pas avoir l'ambition de
dire demain même après demain quand on
dit quand on dit à 40 ans à 20 ans on
change de modèle on a on peut aussi se
donner l'ambition aujourd'hui de passer
vers des aides à l'actif
subventionné les paysans plutôt que les
hectares et à partir du moment où on
aura plus de paysans engager la
transition agroécologique sera bien plus
facile ce débat s'achève je vous
donnerai le mot de la fin Cédric Villani
sortir de la de l'agriculture intensive
c'est forcément renoncé à nos
exportations c'est forcément se
soumettre à la compétition
internationale que ça parce que on va
faire une alimentation à deux vitesses
c'est évident enfin aujourd'hui vous
avez Frédéric denré qui est un
journaliste intéressant sociologue qui a
écrit un bouquin là-dessus aujourd'hui
il y a des classes sociales défavorisées
pour qui ce discours anti-viande est
insupportable pour eux c'est aussi un
marqueur de pouvoir manger un peu dur
mais peut-être pas tous les jours c'est
il y a un espèce de de clivage alors
peut-être indirect ou involontaire
moins de toute manière Jean-Baptiste l'a
dit aussi
inexorable au niveau français
globalement la consommation de viande
baisse progressivement donc il faut
accompagner les filières en transition
et que les consommateurs à travers leur
acte expriment ce qu'il souhaite dans
dans l'élevage de demain mais c'est au
consommateur de commencer à l'exprimer
que les politiques accompagnent ok mais
il faut d'abord que les consommateurs
s'expriment sur le sujet et l'expression
du consommateur c'est par l'acte d'achat
c'est pas en tant que citoyen parce que
quand il est consommateur il fait pas la
même chose sur ce dernier point pour
conclure ce débat Cédric Villani une
consommation à deux vitesses quand on
est pauvre et ben on devra se passer
avec quatre phrases la première c'est
que la consommation de viande au niveau
mondial dans une économie mondialisée
c'est aussi un problème une question
écologique parce que c'est aussi des gaz
à effet de serre c'est aussi de la
déforestation
deuxièmement le système à deux vitesses
mes chers collègues je suis désolé j'ai
l'impression qu'il est déjà là au sens
et il s'agit c'est le boulot du
politique mes chers collègues que de
faire en sorte de corriger slide de
faire en sorte que tout le monde avec
des barres revenus puisse avoir accès à
la viande de bonne qualité bien sûr ce
qui est ce qui est ce qui est
fondamental et on l'a dit on sera tous
d'accord là-dessus c'est qu'on ne peut
pas décorer les débat de la qualité de
la viande et du bien-être du débat du
revenu du juste revenu des fleurs et que
c'est fondamental et la dernière chose
il y a des scénarios il y a en
particulier un signe temps qui s'appelle
Idris Idris qui travaille sur des
transitions là-dessus le scénario ténia
sera agriculture citer ce matin par le
directeur général de Danone travail à
établir un scénario cohérent de
transition à l'échelle entière de
l'Europe là-dessus merci messieurs je
voudrais vous garder juste avec moi un
instant Jean-Baptiste Moreau ainsi
qu'évidemment Cédric Villani notre grand
témoin je voudrais vous montrer cette
femme voulait évoquez tout au début de
l'émission elle s'appelle Emmanuel
charpentier elle est généticienne elle
est française cocorico et elle vient de
recevoir le prix Nobel de chimie pour
ses découvertes sur la technique de
modification du génome appelé Chris prk9
qui permet je sais pas le dire crise
qui permet de couper l'ADN à des
endroits précis c'est intéressant parce
que ça peut aider l'agriculture très
bonne nouvelle tout le monde savait que
que que qu'elle recevrait le prix Nobel
avec sa collaboratrice avec sa ce sont
ce sont deux femmes extraordinaires qui
ont
fait cette découverte qui est une
révolution dans le domaine de la de du
génie génétique on ne pensait pas
forcément que ça viendrait sitôt c'est
une bonne nouvelle souvent les grands
scientifiques reçoivent le prix Nobel 20
ans 30 ans après les découvertes ici
c'est pas le cas et on s'en réjouit là
où il faut faire attention cocorico
c'est qu'elle a pas pu faire sa carrière
en France elle a été aux États-Unis la
France n'a pas retenu mais est-ce que
c'est pas un des aveux pour des
écologistes qui sont aussi OGM le
problème le problème en tout cas c'est
qu'on a aujourd'hui un obscurantisme
scientifique en France qui nous empêche
même d'aborder certains sujets mais si
mais si si Cédric tu peux pas dire le
contraire on a un obscu anti
scientifique là-dessus Chris percasnight
pourquoi elle a pas eu le droit de
développer cette théorie parce que
l'Europe est la une partie de l'Europe
et une partie de la France a décidé que
ça c'était la même chose que des OGM ce
qui n'est absolument pas le cas et ça le
problème dans sa carrière mais j'en
parlerai je connais pas sa carrière
intimement moi je connais un peu ses
recherches et ce qui est certain c'est
que cette technique cette technologie de
sélection du génome peut permettre
justement d'adapter un certain nombre
d'espèces variétales végétales au
changement climatique qui nous menace
avec des on va pouvoir sélectionner des
espèces qui sont moins gourmandes
suicide et vraiment d'un mot pourquoi la
France nous appartenu c'est surtout que
les dispositifs les dispositifs de de
carrière en France n'ont pas pu lui
donner des moyens au niveau qu'elle
méritait allez merci messieurs vous
restez avec moi Cédric Villani fidèle à
Emmanuel Macron mais pas à ça majorité
difficile à suivre on voit ça tout de
suite
[Musique]
Cédric Villani regardez-moi pendant que
Nicolas giron vous donne son livre on
vous dit baroque mathématicien un peu
perché on vous a découvert ambitieux
on vous a découvert stratège également
on vous a aussi découvert vaincu à Paris
comment vos anciens camarades marcheurs
vous regardent aujourd'hui c'est le vu
par des amours d'un Gava vous réagissez
juste après
c'était en juin 2017 si vous voulez
trouver le député Villani cherchez la
lavallière et la broche araignée dans
l'hémicycle on le reconnaît tout de
suite car le député marcheur n'est pas
n'importe qui c'est un médaille et field
une des plus prestigieuses récompenses
dans le monde des mathématiques j'avais
entendu parler de lui mais je ne le
connaissais pas donc ça a été une
découverte de l'Assemblée à mon arrivée
et alors bah c'est Cédric c'est un poème
à lui tout seul c'est un homme brillant
c'est un souvenir c'est une réalité
c'est la première chose que l'on pense
lorsque l'on parle de Cédric Villani
mission sur l'intelligence artificielle
rapporte sur les mathématiques au début
Villani le bon élève reste dans sa zone
de confort mais selon l'expression cher
à Emmanuel Macron il va ensuite prendre
son risque alors qu'en marche lui
préfère Benjamin Griveaux pour mener la
bataille de Paris le bon soldat vilaini
entre en dissidence j'ai décidé d'être
candidat à la prochaine élection du
maire de Paris et c'est peut-être là
aussi que son parcours explique aussi
ses choix je crois qu'il n'a pas su
accepter le rejet qui n'a pas su
accepter une défaite c'est vrai que
Vianney c'est quelqu'un qui
a toujours su avoir raison aussi moi je
pense qu'il est arrivé en politique avec
du talent
de la fraîcheur peut-être un peu de
naïveté et qu'une campagne municipale à
Paris ça prend du talent mais faut
éviter la naïveté l'aventure parisienne
ce solde par un échec électoral et un
divorce politique en mai dernier il
participe à la fondation du groupe
écologique démocratie et solidarité et
fait perdre à la République en marche la
sacro-sainte majorité absolue bien sûr
que c'est une trahison et moi je trouve
que c'est un gâchis
de partir je trouve que c'est une forme
aussi de facilité Cédric Villani se
définit maintenant ni dans la majorité
ni dans l'opposition mais pour 2022
j'espère qu'on se retrouvera en tout cas
qu'un chemin se recroiseront en 2022 si
le président de la République est
candidat j'espère que tous ceux qui ont
été élus grâce au président de la
République continueront de le soutenir
Cédric Villani comment vous réagissez à
tous ces commentaires anaïf qui ne sait
pas perdre qui nous a trahi mais qu'on
espère retrouver en 2022 moi je réagis
surtout en saluant mais les collègues
ceux qui sont exprimés Laetitia avia
Roland Lescure en particulier des gens
que je côtoie encore et ce matin Roland
Lescure présider la commission des
affaires économiques dans laquelle je
siège désormais on a encore eu des
échanges et je les complimenté pour sa
pour sa qualité de président
ça a été une découverte qui a été dit
sur vous je n'ai rien je n'ai rien nié
et j'ai appris des choses dans cette
élection qui ont été fondamentales pour
la suite alors on comprend pas pourquoi
si vous les aimez toujours autant vos
collègues marcheurs pourquoi vous les
avez quittés
de vouloir commencer par se définir en
disant avec qui on est et ensuite ce
qu'on fait ce qu'il faut c'est commencer
par définir ce qu'on veut sur quoi on
croit et ensuite vient naturellement les
regroupements les alliances et on passe
beaucoup trop de temps politique à dire
qu'on veut être avec l'un avec l'autre
ou pas de la politique dans le sens qui
est pas toujours bon de la politique
Aillerie et je je suis dans ce groupe on
a fait les choses dans le bon ordre dans
l'écologie démocratie solidarité nous
avons commencé par définir ce en quoi
nous croyons l'écologie une écologie qui
ne peut se concevoir sans la solidarité
on a eu le l'exemple tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs on peut pas parler d'écologie
dans le domaine de lecture et d'élevage
sans parler de solidarité de modèles
économique de la façon dont la société
valorise l'éleveur
impossible
de la l'écologie impossible sur la
démocratie parce que ce sont des choix
de société qu'est-ce que veut la
République en marche aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas où est le corpus idéologique
quels sont les mots clés qu'est-ce qui
est mis en avant en premier où est le ou
est le le la colonne vertébrale à EDS
nous avons une colonne vertébrale et
c'est là-dessus qu'on s'appuie et quand
hier nous avions ce débat quand nous
avions le débat lundi pardon sur les
néonicotinoïdes nous avions très bien à
EDF ce que nous avions voté pas parce
que nous sommes copains accusés avec les
autres parce que nous avons travaillé le
fond du dossier très en amont parce que
nous savons pour nous les arbitrages
majeurs parce que nous pensons que ces
néonicotinoïdes c'est poison très très
violents utilisés dans dans
l'agriculture et dont on vient de
réautoriser hélas l'utilisation pour la
betterave sucrière pendant peut-être
trois ans nous estimons que pour le
générations futures pour la place de la
France sur la scène écologie dans le
monde il ne le faut pas ça c'est un
choix qui a été fait non pas parce que
par calcul politique n'ont pas pour
préparer une échéance mais par
conviction sur le fond et 2022 Cédric
Villani c'est forcément Macron je crois
que vous n'avez pas écouté ce que je
viens de dire le bon choix c'est pas de
dire avec qui ou contre qui on est
d'abord c'est d'abord dire ce en quoi on
croit et de travailler sur le fond nous
sommes en 2020
qu'il était à l'époque aujourd'hui vous
ne pourriez pas le retrouver pour la
prochaine échéance il était candidat à
nouveau
cher Myriam Kawa que vous n'avez pas
bien écouté ce que je disais les projets
les idées avant les avant les autres ça
c'est un un classique en politique je
vois que vous êtes voilà un habitué tout
le monde le dit je ne sais pas vu le
nombre de personnes qui en tout cas dans
mon entourage
ce que je vois qui parle et qui
réfléchissent comment ils vont se
positionner pour 2022 peut-être que tout
le monde le dit mais ils le font pas en
réalité moi je le fais comment il n'est
pas évident à ce stade que vous
souteniez Emmanuel Macron pour 2022
aujourd'hui je ne soutiens personne ni
pour 2020 ni pour 2021 ni pour 2022
aujourd'hui je travaille mes sujets les
dossiers le texte et je vous le dis on
passe beaucoup trop de temps politique à
dire on est contre un tel ou pour un tel
et pas assez de temps à travailler sur
le fond la position la transition le
sujet de transition agricole dont on
vient de parler ça c'est un vrai sujet
Quel est le programme de la République
en marche pour ça je ne sais pas j'ai
une autre programme je voulais évoquer
vous l'avez bien expliqué ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'assemblée suffit à vos
ambitions je suis un député travaillant
dans ce groupe parlementaire dans lequel
il y a nous sommes une quinzaine avec de
de grandes personnalités que c'est un
plaisir de travailler avec elle je pense
à par la forteresse je pense Delphine
bateau je pensais Émile Carriou et bien
autres mais le Palais Bourbon rien que
le Palais Bourbon pas les régional par
exemple en Île-de-France en tout cas je
ne suis en train de rien préparer pour
les jeunes en revanche il y a un ancrage
local comme il faut en politique il faut
le l'échelon national et un ancrage
local j'ai mon ancrage de député de
l'Essonne bien sûr une circonscription
fascinante extrêmement variée importante
dans laquelle vous avez le plateau de
sacré grand paysage à la fois
d'innovation et d'agriculture mais aussi
mon ancrage de conseiller municipal dans
le 14e arrondissement sur lequel je
m'attache là encore à porter une voix
qui n'est ni dans la majorité ni dans la
position mais pour l'écologie la
démocratie la solidarité
avec nous que s'est-il passé ces
dernières 24 heures au Palais Bourbon
c'est l'heure de la chronique de Thomas
des prés ma journée à l'Assemblée tout
de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir Thomas ravie de vous retrouver
en plateau
Paris en zone d'alerte maximale on le
sait depuis quelques jours du coup
l'assemblée resterait encore un peu plus
son protocole sanitaire qu'est-ce que
quel tour de vie qu'est-ce qu'il va
signifier concrètement alors déjà on
savait qu'il y a déjà eu un certain
nombre de quatre coronavirus cependant
la première vague certains avaient même
parlé d'un cluster de l'assemblée du
coup les services de l'Assemblée veulent
tout faire pour éviter de nouvelles
contaminations alors avec André Lafont
on y était cet après-midi on s'est
baladé dans les couloirs le masque est
obligatoire pour tout le monde même pour
eux
il y a des distributeurs de gel
hydroalcooliques partout ici dans la
salle des quatre colonnes ici à l'entrée
de l'hôtel de lacet et même la bonne
vieille buvette des journalistes a dû
adapter ses horaires fini les apéros
pendant les longues séances nocturnes
dans l'hémicycle en commission c'est
pareil les députés sont tous masqués et
quand l'un de oublie son masque il se
fait vite râper à l'ordre
lorsque vous parlez parce que vous
contaminez monsieur de Courson et c'est
pas une bonne idée
Charles de à l'approche du budget c'est
jamais une bonne idée alors ça c'était
dans les dispositions qui étaient en
place jusqu'à présent mais dès la
semaine prochaine ça change ça va se
durcir depuis que Paris est passé en
zone d'alerte maximale lundi de
nouvelles règles sanitaires ont été
mises en place elles ont été présentées
hier en conférence des présidents par
Richard Ferrand du coup nous on est allé
voir la première vice-présidente de
l'Assemblée la députée les républicains
du Doubs Annie Genval pour qu'elle nous
explique comment ça va se dérouler les
règles à partir de lundi officiellement
et bien officiellement chacun des
groupes sera présent pour moitié dans
l'hémicycle et en commission donc ça
permettra d'abord de réduire le nombre
de personnes présentes dans un même lieu
au fond nous nous plions à ce que vivent
beaucoup de Français qui sont empêchés
de se réunir comme il le voudrait et en
même temps ce dispositif qui réduit de
moitié chacun des groupes permet de
respecter la proportionnalité des
groupes
de façon à ce que les équilibres
politiques soient maintenus donc l'idée
c'est que cette image là on fasse tout
pour ne pas la reconnaître dans les
prochaines semaines exactement ce que
nous voulons éviter c'est effectivement
la constitution de cluster pourquoi tout
simplement parce que ça a beaucoup
handicapé le travail par le notaire or
l'Assemblée nationale doit pouvoir
continuer son travail le plus
normalement possible voilà Myriam tout
faire pour éviter un nouveau cluster
comme dit à Annie Jeanne Var ses
nouvelles règles seront en place
officiellement dès lundi mais d'ici là
les députés ont déjà été invités à
réduire leur présence à l'assemblée et à
faire travailler leurs collaborateurs
davantage en télétravail merci Thomas
merci Madame deuxième grand
être ce conflit aux portes de l'Europe
auxquelles nous assistons depuis une
semaine comme un peu impuissant
[Musique]
bonsoir galet Ackermann je suis ravie de
vous accueillir dans cette émission vous
êtes historienne spécialiste des pays de
l'Est spécialistes également de la
Russie ça va être utile pour décrypter
ce qu'il se passe actuellement de le
haut Karaba et bienvenue sur ce plateau
guitier bonsoir vous êtes députés les
républicains des Bouches-du-Rhône membre
de la commission de la défense que vous
avez longtemps présidé ici même vous
sortez à l'instant d'une audition du
ministre des Affaires étrangères
Jean-Yves Le Drian peut-être vous nous
en direz un mot ça portait sur ce
conflit et vous avez signé cette tribune
dans le JDD ce dimanche avec près de 200
élus appelant la France à soutenir
l'Arménie on va en parler mais
évidemment c'est un dossier complexe pas
si lointain mais complexe les clés pour
comprendre tout de suite avec Emilie ETI
[Musique]
à qui appartient le haut Karaba son
statut est très particulier il s'agit
d'une république autoproclamée depuis
1991 jamais reconnu par l'ONU peuplé en
majorité par des Arméniens voilà
pourquoi ce territoire est revendiqué
par l'Arménie mais officiellement le
haut-karaba reste toujours rattaché à
l'Azerbaïdjan dont il a été séparé après
la chute de l'empire soviétique à la fin
des années 80 le conflit dur depuis près
de 30 ans début 90 des affrontements ont
fait 30 000 morts et des centaines de
milliers de déplacés depuis 1994 le
cessez-le-feu instauré par la Russie et
régulièrement violée comme en 2016 ou
des heures éclate entre les deux pays
le 27 septembre dernier la région s'est
à nouveau embrasée qui a déclenché les
combats
cette offensive de grande envergure a
été lancé par l'armée azeri équipée
d’avions de chasse de chars et de drones
de combat les populations civiles
essentiellement arméniennes sont prises
au piège des bombardements de nombreuses
victimes sont à déplorer
parallèlement au combat les deux pays
mènent une vraie guerre de l'information
chacun accuse en l'autre d'être le
responsable de cet escalade militaire
quels sont les enjeux c'est
l'Azerbaïdjan turcophone musulmans et
l’arménie chrétienne qui s'affrontent
dans cette enclave montagneuse guerre
par procuration entre deux puissances
d'un côté la Turquie d'ardoise et de
l'autre la Russie de Poutine
premier alliée de laserbaïdjan la
Turquie souhaite maintenir son influence
dans cette région riche en hydrocarbures
l'aide de Moscou aux Arméniens elle est
plus fragile car Moscou joue un double
jeu en vendant des armes aux deux
belligerons de son côté la France a
appelé à un cesser le feu immédiat tout
en appliquant un principe de neutralité
Karman difficile d'avoir un bilan très
précis chiffré des deux côtés que
sait-on alors on se parle de la
situation sur place environ 250 morts
mais pas seulement du côté du haut
Karaba arménien des deux côtés bien sûr
en fait il y a parallèlement au combat
une sorte de guerre d'information ou
l'Arménie d'un côté et l'Azerbaïdjan de
l'autre
rapporte leur victoire respective les en
disent les azériques ils ont
occupés tant de villages donc qui font
partie du haut karabaque ou de la zone
frontalière entre les deux
et les intérêts par exemple démente ça
tantôt les azeries disent que le chef
militaire du okaraba qui a été blessé
ensuite c'est démenti etc donc en fait
il est très difficile de connaître la
vérité parce que parce que encore une
fois on sait que maintenant n'importe
quelle guerre est une guerre hybride et
à la bataille et il y a le combat
d'information dans cette affaire c'est
l'Azerbaïdjan qui ouvre les hostilités
c'est l'agresseur qui qui est
l'Azerbaïdjan pourquoi les azeries
frappent maintenant personne ne s'y
attendait
vous savez ça fait 30 ans il faut quand
même rappeler les faits que
le haut karabaq a proclamé son
indépendance ce n'était pas rare à
l'époque vers la fin de l'époque
soviétique il y avait d'autres
territoires qui ont proclamé leur
indépendant et si pour les républiques
fédérales selon la Constitution
soviétique il était possible de quitter
l'Union soviétique les républiques
autonomes qui appartenaient toute à
différentes républiques fédérées
n'avaient pas ce droit l’exemple le plus
frappant c'est les Tchétchénie en fait
la Tchétchénie a proclamé
unilatéralement son indépendance et pour
la Russie c'était en casus Belly et on
sait très bien que il y a eu deux
guerres extrêmement cruelle et ça c'est
terminé par la reconquête de la
Tchétchénie maintenant le haut karabaq
il faut bien distinguer entre la
situation humanitaire
bien sûr si maintenant les inseries
arrivent à occuper une partie où tout le
haut carambar cela veut dire
probablement nettoyage ethnique
nettoyage ethnique alors on va essayer
de comprendre il y a pas beaucoup en
fait d'habitants au karabach qui sont
évidemment d'origine arménienne c'est
150000 à peu près c'est ça même moi
c'est tout à fait ça donc moi ce que je
voudrais dire d'abord c'est à la guerre
le principal adversaire c'est le
mensonge et c'est pour corroborer ce que
vous disiez madame en fait il y a la
guerre des morts la guerre des chars
détruits etc etc mais je pense qu'il
faut revenir à l'histoire alors
justement allons-y parce que personne ne
connaît bien cette région c'est très
compliqué
à l'origine à l'origine déjà le karaba
est une terre arménienne j'y suis allé
tout témoin de la présence chrétienne
sur ce territoire de très vieille
églises qui datent du 12e siècle etc et
ce territoire a été occupé à 90% par les
Arméniens aujourd'hui les Arméniens ont
été complètement spoliées de leur
présence sur cette terre puisque il ne
leur reste à peu près que 10% de ce
qu'il possédait autrefois avec le
royaume de Sidi si etc pour bien
comprendre 1991 je continue et il y a
cette petite enclave ce qui est petite
qui est à peu près grande comme un ou
deux départements français sur lequel
vivent 150 000 personnes
qui se sont retrouvés effectivement
comme le disait madame par cette espèce
de jeu de domino de Staline qui a décidé
pour ce ménager les bonnes grâces des
azéries l'Azerbaïdjan n'existait pas
c'était la Turquie à l'origine de donner
ce territoire qui était un territoire de
montagne qu'on appelle le jardin noir
dur difficile après aux azéries
effectivement
dès que ces peuples avec la chute de
l'Union soviétique déjà avec la paix
historica les Arméniens ont fait valoir
leurs droits en disant mais il faut
qu'on retrouve nos terres on est on est
chez nous il faut qu'on sorte de cet
accord qui avait scellé Staline à
l'époque et donc elle a commencé si vous
voulez des agressions et notamment il y
a aussi beaucoup d'Arméniens qui
viennent à naza abaku d'ailleurs qui ont
fait l'objet de programme et là on est
rentré dans l'envah 1991 et une date
importante dans les produits
rajouter une chose c'est que les
Arméniens ont subi le premier génocide
de ces dernières années et que voilà de
1915 sous le gouvernement jeune turc
donc il faut remettre tout ça dans
l'histoire et aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
très bien que derrière les herbaïdjan il
y a une puissance qui revient tentée par
ses vieux démons une puissance
hégémonique qui est la Turquie qu'on
retrouve partout
Cédric Villani un premier mot pour dire
que moi aussi j'ai signé cette pétition
cette tribune en tout cas j'ai dit quand
on m'a quand on m'a demandé est-ce que
tes signataires j'ai dit j'ai dit oui
c'était suffisamment tôt dans cette
affaire en tout cas s'engage ici là
maintenant il s'agit pas de dire qu'il y
a des bons et des gentils il s'agit pas
de nier que c'est un territoire de
conflit mais il s'agit de dire ici là
sur cette affaire il y a un agresseur
bien identifié ensuite c'est un c'est
une région du monde dans laquelle
l'influence de la a été reconnu dans
laquelle l'histoire la culture est là et
l'importance diplomatique aussi et la
France doit assumer cela être au
rendez-vous et ensuite je souscris tout
à fait à ce qui était dit à l'instant
sur la question de turc qu'on retrouve
aussi dans le dossier grec sur lequel la
France a eu raison c'est cet été de
d'intervenir de manifester sa présence
parce qu'il y a aujourd'hui une volonté
de d'influence expansionniste du côté de
la Turquie qui est tout à fait mal venu
dans le climat actuel et qu'il ne faut
surtout pas laisser faire
Erdogan et de la Turquie est-ce qu'elle
tient des ficelles à quoi jouir Dogan
juste pour comprendre parce que on a
compris l'histoire ancienne 1991 le
Karaba devient indépendant parce que en
gros les habitants soutenus par les
l'armée arménienne réussissent proclamer
la souveraineté dans ce territoire là
tout est organisé politiquement comme si
on était dans un état
républiques non reconnus sur l'ensemble
de l'Union soviétique
vous savez il y a la Transnistrie le
cessé du Sud et la quasi et pourtant la
communauté internationale ne reconnaît
pas le haut Karaba comme comme un état
au regard du droit international mais
donc ces deux principes le droit des
peuples d'un côté et l'intégrité de
l'autre mais absolument c'est exactement
ce que ça veut dire formellement au
moment de la proclamation de
l'indépendance par l'Azerbaïdjan Leo
karabaque faisait partie de les airbags
et donc si on commence à reconnaître
bien sûr on ouvre une boîte de Pandore
c'est c'est en fait ça le fait ça le
problème le problème c'est que ça ouvre
à d'autres pays qui pourraient
revendiquer leur ind épendance totale
bien sûr alors on va parler de la
Turquie parce que je voudrais vous faire
entendre le président français qui a
donné des précisions justement sur le
rôle de la Turquie dans ce conflit
écoutez Emmanuel Macron
300 combattants ont quitté la scierie
pour rejoindre Bakou en passant par gaz
antip
ces combattants sont connus tracés
identifiés ils viennent de groupes
djihadistes qui opère dans la région
d'Alep
c'est un état de fait et d'autres
contingences prépa à peu près de la même
taille
l'accusation est très forte le président
français accuse Erdogan d'envoyer des
djihadistes qui sont en Turquie
en Azerbaïdjan pour pour les aider dans
ce conflit
occupée par les Turcs effectivement mais
le président ne fait pas ça la légère le
président n'a la preuve et à la
certitude on est on est certain de ça
aujourd'hui les mains sur les Turcs le
contestent
l'engagement de ces mercenaires donne un
tour tout à fait nouveau à ce conflit ce
qui me choque actuellement c'est que
dans le groupe de minks où se trouvent
les Russes qui jouent un jeu curieux et
France bien depuis 30 ans on a
l'impression que ces trois puissances se
satisfont de ce statu quo et que
finalement s'arrange bien tout le monde
on te tentant pouf ça s'enflamme il y a
des dizaines des centaines voir des
milliers de morts et puis ça se calme
cet après-midi
Monsieur Le Drian s'exprimait devant la
commission des affaires étrangères et au
fond il ne disait rien d'autre que nous
voulons un cesser le feu
l'arrêt de du conflit sans aucune
intervention d'aucune des parties
simplement pour que le conflit s'arrête
mais on ne résout rien ça veut dire que
ça recommencera donc je trouve que je
vous le dis parce que je le pense
pourquoi priver
cet enclave ce petit pays de faire
d'avoir recours à un référendum pour
pour avoir son indépendant
superviser ça et la France pourrait être
ce pays pour dire bon alors
en fait monsieur le derme dit non non
mais les Arméniens nous demandent
n'aiment pas ça ils demandent simplement
qu'on arrête qu'on arrête le combat les
combats et puis que nous discutions nous
mettions autour de la table pour avoir
une paix durable
la seule solution d'avoir une paix
durable c'est d'intégrer cet enclave à
la République d'Arménie tout à l'heure
vous évoquez au fond le risque d'une
épuration ethnique parce qu'Erdogan il
explique très clairement qu'un cessez le
feu ne sera possible que si les
Arméniens du haut carabar se retirent
est-ce qu'on peut regarder ces menaces
sans rien dire
bien sûr que non mais vous savez ce qui
m'étonne c'est tout à fait normal que en
France qui a toujours eu des liens très
spéciaux avec l'herminie il y a beaucoup
de voies appelant à une intervention
mais en fait
celle qui devrait intervenir et
n'intervient pas c'est la Russie alors
Poutine
non bien sûr pas seulement parce que
c'est chrétiens mais c'est parce que il
y a aussi des bases militaires en
Arménie en fait c'est son ancrage dans
le Caucase et bien sûr la question se
pose pourquoi si vous comparez les
situations on a eu en 2008 après une
sorte de provocation
sac à Chevilly donc le président
georgien de l'époque qui a voulu
reconquérir aussi une enclave
indépendante qui était le City du Sud
tout de suite non seulement les eaux 7
mais les Russes
les Diogène aussi dans en réalité il y
en avait pas et les troupes russes
sont entrés en Géorgie et c'est
uniquement en grande partie grâce à
l'intervention de Nicolas Sarkozy que
donc voici vous considérez que la
communauté internationale pour conclure
ne peut pas rester attentif non ce que
je veux dire c'est que moi je me pose la
question pourquoi en 2008 la Russie a
bien voulu intervenir parce que les
situations est exactement pareil elle a
vu que la balle est dans le camp de foot
défendre les osettes qui sont encore
moins nombreux il y a quelques dizaines
de milliers seulement et pourquoi
aujourd'hui
on ne veut pas la Russie ne veut pas
c'est le volet et le leur est déjà fait
intervenir on va essayer de suivre ce
dossier question sans réponse pour
l'instant peut-être qu'il y a des jeux
sur qui Russie
sur lequel la France devra assumer
des responsabilités dans lequel le
président a raison d'un employé un temps
ferme merci beaucoup de courage merci à
tous les trois
c'est votre éclairage sur ce dossier
complexe c'est la fin de cette émission
n'oubliez pas le pasteur dont 36-20 ou
pasteur don.fr s'il y a un moment il
faut aider la recherche en pleine crise
sanitaire pour trouver un vaccin seul
maintenant très belle soirée à demain
[Musique]